>>> THIS IS CNN BREAKING NEWS.
>>> WELCOME TO OUR VIEWERS IN
THE UNITED STATES AND ALL AROUND
THE WORLD.
IT IS THURSDAY, MARCH 17th, WE
DO HAVE BREAKING NEWS, PERHAPS
MIRACULOUS NEWS.
WORD THAT PEOPLE ARE ALIVE AND
EMERGING FROM THE MARIUPOL
THEATER THAT WAS HIT AND MORE OR
LESS FLATTEN BD ED BY A STRIKE.
AND THERE IS WORD THAT PERHAPS
HUNDREDS MANY PEOPLE WERE
TRAPPED INSIDE.
BEFORE THE BOMBING, THE WORD
CHILDREN WRITTEN ON THE GROUND
IN RUSSIAN.
THIS IS A MESSAGE THAT THERE ARE
CIVILIANS IN THE BUILDING.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN VIDEO FROM THE
THEATER TAKEN A WEEK AGO.
SO MANY PEOPLE, HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS, HAVE BEEN SHELTERING
THERE.
AGAIN, THE NEWS THIS MORNING IS
THAT CREWS ARE ABLE TO CLEAR THE
RUBBLE, ALLOWING PEOPLE TO WALK
OUT.
SOME ARE EMERGING.
A KEY AID TO PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY TOLD US THAT MANY ARE
AND TRYING TO GET MORE
INFORMATION AT THIS TIME.
>>> NOW, A COUPLE MILES AWAY A
BUILDING THAT HOUSES A PUBLIC
SWIMMING POOL, IT WAS ALSO HIT.
OFFICIALS SAY THE BUILDING WAS
HOUSING PREGNANT WOMEN AND WOMEN
WITH CHILDREN UNDER 3 YEARS OLD.
YOU CAN SEE THE DESTRUCTION
THERE.
AND JUST HOURS BEFORE A CURFEW
IN CAPITAL KYIV SET TO EXPIRE.
A NEW ATTACK ON RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING THERE.
AT LEAST ONE PERSON KILLED WHEN
PART OF A DOWNED MISSILE HIT THE
BUILDING.
NOW, DESPITE ALL OF THIS
EVIDENCE THAT EVERYONE CAN SEE
WITH THEIR OWN EYES, RUSSIA
DENIES THAT THEY'RE TARGETING
CIVILIANS.
KYIV'S MAYOR IS HAVING NONE OF
IT.
>> THEY DESTROYED -- THEY KILLED
CHILDREN.
WOMEN, CITIZENS.
THEY -- FOR WHAT REASON?
>> PUTIN SAYS HE'S ONLY
TARGETING MILITARY TARGETS.
BULLSHIT, SORRY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN WITH HIS
STRONGEST CONDEMNATION YET OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
FOR THE FIRST TIME CALLING HIM A
WAR CRIMINAL FOR HIS ATTACKS ON
UKRAINIAN CIVILIANS.
PUTIN RESPONDING TO THAT CHARGE
JUST MOMENTS AGO.
BUT SOME EXAMPLES HERE, MUCH OF
THE SMALL CITY OF VOLNOVAKHA,
AND YOU CAN SEE WHAT IS LOOKS
LIKE BEFORE THE INVASION.
THIS IS JUST THE NEIGHBORHOOD,
YOU SEE THE ROUND-ABOUT THERE,
SURROUNDED BY HOMES AND
BUILDINGS, NOW YOU SEE THE AREA
TOTALLY FLATTENED.
A SENIOR ADVISER TO PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY SAYS UKRAINIAN FORCES
ARE BEGINNING TO COUNTERSTRIKE
AGAINST THE RUSSIANS.
THIS IS VIDEO THAT SHOWS BLOWN
UP VEHICLES AT THE KHERSON
AIRPORT.
IN MARIUPOL, FORCES TAKING OUT A
MILITARY TANK.
AND IN A PLEA TO A VIRTUAL
ADDRESS, HE INVOKED THE
HOLOCAUST.
AND HE CALLED ON THE GERMAN
CHANCELLOR TO DESTROY THE WALL
THAT IS SEPARATING EUROPE.
>> NOW IS WLADIMIR KLITSCHKO,
THE BROTHER OF THE MAYOR IN
KYIV.
HE'S FIGHTING FOR THE DEFENSE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
A 36-HOUR CURFEW HAS BEEN
INSTITUTED IN YOUR CITY.
THAT HAS NOW BEEN LIFTED.
CAN YOU TELL ME THE SITUATION ON
THE GROUND THIS MORNING?
>> FOR UKRAINIANS, TODAY, ON THE
GROUND, SPEAKING OF THE COUNTRY,
MUCH OF THE COUNTRY, AS WELL AS
THE SOUTH, HAS BEEN ATTACKED.
AS YOU KNOW ALREADY THAT THE
TARGETS ARE CIVILIANS.
AND THIS HAS BEEN REPEATED
MULTIPLE TIMES, SUCH CITIES,
BUCHA, SATELLITE CITIES OF THE
CAPITAL OF UKRAINE, CITY OF
KYIV, HAVE BEEN DESTROYED.
90% OF MARIUPOL HAS BEEN
BOMBARDED AND DESTROYED.
JUST LUCKILY, THE THEATER WHERE
UP TO 1,000 CHILDREN, INNOCENT,
IN THE BUILDING, WERE DESTROYED
BUT THEY WERE UNDERGROUND, SO
THEY SURVIVED.
THAT WAS LUCK.
BUT THE TARGETS OF THE RUSSIAN
ARMY ARE CIVILIANS.
THIS IS GENOCIDE OF THE
UKRAINIAN POPULATION.
THOSE ROCKETS ARE FLYING AND
DESTROYING NOT JUST THE
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE COUNTRY,
BUT KILLING THE INNOCENT.
AND THAT'S A MEAT OATTER OF FAC.
KYIV IS STILL STANDING STRONG.
THE RUSSIAN ARMY IS TRYING TO
CIRCLE THE CITY.
THEY'RE HAVING NO SUCCESS.
WE'RE STANDING STRONG.
OUR WILL IS STRONG.
AND, HONESTLY, I'M PROUD OF OUR
WOMEN AND MEN THAT STAND
TOGETHER AGAINST THIS RUSSIAN
WAR AGGRESSION.
>> WE CAN SEE RIGHT HERE THE
RUSSIAN FORCES TRYING TO
ENCIRCLE THE CITY OF KYIV FROM
ALL DIRECTIONS.
BUT IT'S LARGELY BEEN THE
SITUATION FOR A FEW DAYS.
WE HAVE WORD FROM SOME UKRAINIAN
OFFICIALS THAT UKRAINIAN FORCES
HAVE LAUNCHED A COUNTEROFFENSIVE
AGAINST THE RUSSIANS.
WHAT YOU CAN TELL US ABOUT THAT?
>> THERE IS A LOT OF SPANNING,
I'M NOT A MILITARY MAN WITH
OFFICE BEHIND ME, SO I CANNOT
MAKE OFFICIAL STATEMENTS WHAT
HAS BEEN DONE, BUT EVENTUALLY,
RUSSIAN BOOTS AND RUSSIAN
EQUIPMENT NEED TO LEAVE OUR
TERRITORY.
OUR SERENITY OF OUR COUNTRY.
AND JUST LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
EVENTUALLY, IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THE SOONER IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
THE BETTER IT IS.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT TO DELIVERING,
OR AT LEAST PROMISING TO DELIVER
AND IT WAS CONFIRMED DELIVERING
OF THEIR MILITARY EQUIPMENT.
AS WELL AS ENGLAND.
SO THIS AID, THIS MILITARY AID,
IS VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
PROTECT OUR CHOICE TO LIVE IN
FREE COUNTRY AND PROTECT OUR
BORDERS AND GET OUT THE RUSSIAN
BOOTS, AS I SAID, OUT OF OUR
COUNTRY.
>> AS PART OF THAT MILITARY AID,
THERE IS WORD THIS MORNING IT
DOES INCLUDE SOME DRONES, THESE
SWITCH BLADE DRONES THAT DESTROY
WHEN THEY LAND.
WHAT DIFFERENCE DO YOU THINK
THIS WILL MAKE?
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT DIFFERENCE
IT'S GOING TO MAKE, BUT AS I
SAID, ANY AID, ESPECIALLY
MILITARY AID, IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT TO DEFEND OUR COUNTRY.
WE ARE FIGHTING.
BUT WE ALSO NEED SUPPORT OF OUR
ALLIES.
WE NEED HUMANITARIAN HELP,
BECAUSE A LOT OF CIVILIANS ARE
STRUGGLING.
WE NEED THE SUPPORT CRUCIALLY.
AND WE NEED TO STOP PUTIN'S WAR.
WE NEED TO STOP AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE.
THE SOONER IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
THE MORE SEVERE THE LIVES, OR
LIVES IN GENERAL WE'LL SAVE.
>> GERMAN CHANCELLOR HAS SAID
SOMETHING THIS MORNING PRETTY
MUCH SAID BY EVERY NATO NATION
UP UNTIL NOW, THEY WILL HELP
WHILE THEY CAN, KNOW THERE WILL
BE NO NATO MILITARY ASSISTANCE
INSIDE.
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> WE'RE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF
OURSELVES, WE PROMISE.
WE PROMISE WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
CARE OURSELVES, WHICH WE'VE DONE
ALREADY IN THE PAST 21 DAYS OF
THIS SENSELESS WAR.
WHAT WE NEED, WE NEED MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
DELIVER IT.
AND WE WILL DEFEND OURSELVES.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE SKIES
BY OURSELVES.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THE JOB,
BECAUSE WE'RE DEFENDING OUR
COUNTRY.
BUT ALSO DEFENDING THE FREEDOM
AND PEACE IN EUROPE.
AND THE WESTERN WORLD.
AND WE'RE DEFENDING THE
HYPOCRITICAL PRINCIPLES OF EVERY
OTHER COUNTRY OF OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS.
WE ARE NOT ALONE, WE KNOW THAT.
AS I SAID, I'LL SAY IT ONE MORE
TIME, THIS WAR IS AGAINST
HUMANITY.
THIS WAR IS AGAINST PEACE.
TH